[SQUEAKING]
[PAPER RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
YUFEI ZHAO: Last time we started
talking about Roth's theorem,
and we showed a Fourier
analytic proof of Roth's theorem
in the finite field model.
So Roth's theorem
in F3 to the N.
And I want to today show
you how to modify that proof
to work in integers.
And this will be basically
Roth's original proof
of his theorem.
OK.
So what we'll prove
today is the statement
that the size of the largest
3AP-free subset of 1 through N
is, at most, N divided
by log log N. OK,
so we'll prove a
bound of this form.
The strategy of this proof
will be very similar to the one
that we had from last time.
So let me review for you
what is the strategy.
So from last time, the
proof had three main steps.
In the first step, we
observed that if you
are in the 3AP-free set then
there exists a large Fourier
coefficient.
From this Fourier
coefficient, we
were able to extract
a large subspace where
there is a density increment.
I want to modify that
strategy so that we
can work in the integers.
Unlike an F2 to
the N, where things
were fairly nice and clean,
because you have subspaces,
you can take a
Fourier coefficient,
pass it down to a subspace.
There is no subspaces, right?
There are no subspaces
in the integers.
So we have to do something
slightly different,
but in the same spirit.
So you'll find a large
Fourier coefficient.
And we will find that there
is density increment when
you restrict not to
subspaces, but what
could play the role of subspaces
when it comes to the integers?
So I want something which
looks like a smaller
version of the original space.
So instead of it
being integers, if we
restrict to a subprogression,
so to a smaller arithmetic
progression.
I will show that you can
restrict to a subprogression
where you can obtain
density increment.
So we'll restrict integers
to something smaller.
And then, same as last time,
we can iterate this increment
to obtain the
conclusion that you
have an upper bound on the
size of this 3AP-free set.
OK, so that's the strategy.
So you see the same strategy
as the one we did last time,
and many of the ingredients
will have parallels,
but the execution will
be slightly different,
especially in the
second step where,
because we no longer
have sub spaces, which
are nice and clean,
so that's why
we started with a
finite fuel model, just
to show how things work in
a slightly easier setting.
And today, we'll see how to
do a same kind of strategy
here, where there is going
to be a bit more work.
Not too much more,
but a bit more work.
OK, so before we
start, any questions?
All right.
So last time I used the
proof Roth's theorem
as an excuse to introduce
Fourier analysis.
And we're going to see basically
the same kind of Fourier
analysis, but it's going to take
on a slightly different form,
because we're not working
at F3 to the N. We're
working inside the integers.
And there's a general theory of
Fourier analysis on the group,
on a billion groups.
I don't want to go into that
theory, because that's--
I want to focus on
the specific case,
but the point is that
given the billion groups,
you always have a dual
group of characters.
And they play the role
of Fourier transform.
Specifically in
the case of Z, we
have the following
Fourier transform.
So the dual group of Z
turns out to be the torus.
So real numbers mod one.
And the Fourier
transform is defined
as follows, starting with a
function on the integers, OK.
If you'd like, let's say
it's finitely supported,
just to make our
lives a bit easier.
Don't have to deal
with technicalities.
But in general, the
following formula holds.
We have this Fourier
transform defined
by setting f hat of theta
to be the following sum.
OK, where this e is actually
somewhat standard notation,
additive combinatorics.
It's e to the 2
pi i t, all right?
So it goes a fraction, t,
around the complex unit circle.
OK.
So that's the Fourier
transform on the integers.
OK, so you might have seen this
before under a different name.
This is usually
called Fourier series.
All right.
You know, the notation
may be slightly different.
OK, so that's what
we'll see today.
And this Fourier transform plays
the same role as the Fourier
transform from last time, which
was on the group F3 to the N.
And just us in--
so last time, we had a number
of important identities,
and we'll have the same
kinds of identities here.
So let me remind
you what they are.
And the proofs are all
basically the same,
so I won't show you the proofs.
f hat of 0 is simply the
sum of f over the domain.
We have this Plancherel Parseval
identity, which tells us
that if you look at
the inner product
by linear form in
the physical space,
it equals to the inner
product in the Fourier space.
OK.
So in the physical
space now, you sum.
In the frequency space,
you take integral
over the torus, or the
circle, in this case.
It's a one-dimensional torus.
There is also the Fourier
inversion formula,
which now says that f of x
is equal to f hat of theta.
E of x theta, you integrate
theta from 0 to 1.
Again, on the torus,
on the circle.
And third-- and finally, there
was this identity last time
that related three-term
arithmetic progressions
to the Fourier transform, OK?
So this last one was
slightly not as--
I mean, it's not as standard
as the first several, which are
standard Fourier identities.
But this one will
be useful to us.
So the identity relating the
Fourier transform, the 3AP, now
has the following form.
OK, so if we define
lambda of f, g,
and h to be the
following sum, which
sums over all 3APs
in the integers,
then one can write
this expression
in terms of the Fourier
transform as follows.
OK.
All right.
So comparing this formula to the
one that we saw from last time,
it's the same formula,
where different domains,
where you're summing
or integrating,
but it's the same formula.
And the proof is the same.
So go look at the proof.
It's the same proof.
OK.
So these are the key Fourier
things that we'll use.
And then we'll try to
follow on those with--
the same as the proof as last
time, and see where we can get.
So let me introduce
one more notation.
So I'll write lambda sub 3
of f to be lambda of f, f, f,
three times.
OK.
So at this point, if you
understood the lecture
from last time, none of
anything I've said so far
should be surprising.
We are working
integers, so we should
look at the corresponding
Fourier transform in integers.
And if you follow your
notes, this is all the things
that we're going to use.
OK, so what was one
of the first things
we mentioned regarding
the Fourier transform
from last time after this point?
OK.
AUDIENCE: The counting lemma.
YUFEI ZHAO: OK.
So let's do a counting lemma.
So what should the
counting lemma say?
Well, the spirit of the counting
lemma is that if you have two
functions that are close to
each other-- and now, "close"
means close in Fourier--
then their corresponding number
of 3APs should be similar, OK?
So that's what we want to say.
And indeed, right, so
the counting lemma for us
will say that if f and g
are functions on Z, and--
such that their L2 norms are
both bounded by this M. OK,
the sum of the squared absolute
value entries are both bounded.
Then the difference
of their 3AP counts
should not be so different
from each other if f
and g are close in Fourier, OK?
And that means that if all
the Fourier coefficients of f
minus g are small,
then lambda 3ff,
which considers 3AP counts
in f, is close to that of g.
OK.
Same kind of 3AP counting
lemma from last time.
OK, so let's prove it, OK?
As with the counting
lemma proofs
you've seen several times
already in this course,
we will prove it by first
writing this difference
as a telescoping sum.
The first term
being f minus g f f,
and then g of f minus g f and
lambda g, g, f, f minus g.
OK, and we will like to show
that each of these terms
is small if f minus g has
small Fourier coefficients.
OK.
So let's bound the first term.
OK, so let me bound this first
term using the 3AP identity,
relating 3AP to
Fourier coefficients,
we can write this lambda
as the following integral
over Fourier coefficients.
And now, let me--
OK, so what was the
trick last time?
So we said let's pull
out one of these guys
and then use triangle inequality
on the remaining factors.
OK, so we'll do that.
So far, so good.
And now you see this integral.
Apply Cauchy-Schwartz.
OK, so apply Cauchy-Schwartz
to the first factor,
you got this l2 sum,
this l2 integral.
And then you apply
Cauchy-Schwartz
to the second factor.
You get that integral.
OK, now what do we do?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, so yeah.
So you see an l2 of Fourier,
the first automatic reaction
should be to use a
Plancherel or Parseval, OK?
So apply Plancherel identity
to each of these factors.
We find that each
of those factors
is equal to this l2 sum
in the physical space.
OK, so this square
root, the same thing.
Square root again.
OK.
And then we find
that because there
was an hypothesis--
in the hypothesis,
there was a bound M on
this sum of squares.
You have that down there.
And similarly, with
the other two terms.
OK.
So that proves the
counting lemma.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Last time, the
term on the right-hand side
was the maximum over
non-zero frequency?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK.
OK.
So the question is, last time
we had a counting lemma that
looked slightly different.
But I claimed they're all
really the same counting lemma.
They're all the same proofs.
If you run this
proof, it won't work.
If you take what
we did last time,
it's the same kind of proofs.
So last time we had
a counting lemma
where we had the same
f, f, f essentially.
We know have-- I allow you
to essentially take three
different things, and--
OK, so both-- in
both cases, you're
running through
this calculation,
but they look
slightly different.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: So, yeah.
So I agree.
It doesn't look
exactly the same,
but if you think about
what's involved in the proof,
they're the same proofs.
OK.
Any more questions?
All right.
So now, we have
this counting lemma,
so let's start our proof of
Roth's theorem in the integers.
As with last time, there
will be three steps,
as mentioned up there, OK?
In the first step, let us
show that if you are 3AP-free,
then we can obtain a density--
a large Fourier coefficient.
Yeah, so in this course,
this counting lemma,
we actually solved this--
basically this kind of proof
for the first time when we
discussed graph counting
lemma, back in the chapter
on Szemerédi's regularity lemma.
And sure, they all
look literally--
not exactly the same,
but they're all really
the same kind of proofs, right?
So I want--
I'm showing you the same thing
in many different guises.
But they're all the same proofs.
So if you are a set
that is 3AP-free--
and as with last time,
I'm going to call
alpha the density of A now
inside this progression,
this length N progression.
And suppose N is large enough.
OK, so the conclusion now is
that there exists some theta
such that if you look
at this sum over here
as a sum over both integers--
actually, let me do
the sum only from 1
to uppercase N. Claim that--
OK, so-- so it's saying
what this title says.
If you are 3AP-free
and this N is large
enough relative to the density,
you think of this density
alpha is a constant, then
I can find a large Fourier
coefficient.
Now, there's a small
difference, and this
is related to what you
were asking earlier,
between how we set things up now
versus what happened last time.
So last time, we just looked
for a Fourier coefficient
corresponding to a non-zero r.
Now, I'm not
restricting non-zero,
but I don't start with
an indicator function.
I start with the demeaned
indicator function.
I take out the mean so that
the zeroth coefficient,
so to speak, which corresponds
to the mean, is already 0.
So you don't get to use
that for your coefficient.
So if you didn't do
this, if you just
tried to do this
last time, I mean,
you can also do
exactly the same setup.
But if you don't
demean it, then--
if you don't have this
term, then this statement
is trivially true, because I
can take theta equal to 0, OK?
But I don't want.
I want an actual significant
Fourier improvement.
So I take--
I do this demean, and then
I consider its Fourier
coefficient.
OK.
Any questions about
the statement?
Yeah, so this demeaning is
really important, right?
So that's something that's a
very common technique whenever
you do these kind of analysis.
So make sure you're--
so that you're-- yeah, so you're
looking at functions with mean
0.
Let's see the proof.
We have the
following information
about all 3AP counts in A.
Because A is 3AP-free, OK,
so what is the value of lambda
sub 3 of the indicator of A?
Lambda of 3, if you
look at the expression,
it basically sums over all
3APs, but A has no 3APs,
except for the trivial ones.
So we'll only consider
the trivial 3APs,
which has size exactly
the size of A, which
is alpha N from trivial 3APs.
On the other hand, what
do we know about lambda 3
of this interval from 1 to N?
OK, so how many 3APs are there?
OK, so roughly, it's going
to be about N squared over 2.
And in fact, it will be
at least N squared over 2,
because to generate
a 3AP, I just
have to pick a first
term and a third term,
and I'm OK as long as
they're the same parity.
And then you have a 3AP.
So the same parity
cuts you down by half,
so you have at least N squared
over 2 3APs from 1 through N.
So now, let's look at
how to apply the counting
lemma all to the setting.
So we have the counting
lemma up there,
where I now want to apply it--
so apply counting
to, on one hand,
the indicator function of A
so we get the count 3APs in A,
but also compared to
the normalized indicator
on the interval.
OK, so maybe this is
a good point for me
to pause and remind you that
the spirit of this whole proof
is understanding structure
versus pseudorandomness, OK?
So as was the case last time.
So we want to understand, in
what ways is A pseudorandom?
And here, "pseudorandom,"
just as with last time,
means having small
Fourier coefficients,
being Fourier uniform.
If A is pseudorandom,
which here, means f and g
are close to each other.
That's what being
pseudorandom means,
then the counting
lemma will tell us
that f and g should
have similar AP counts.
But A has basically no AP
count, so they should not
be close to each other.
So that's the strategy, to
show that A is not pseudorandom
in this sense, and thereby
extracting a large Fourier
coefficient.
So we apply counting
to these two functions,
and we obtain that.
OK.
So this quantity, which
corresponds to lambda 3 of g,
minus alpha N. So these were
lambda 3 of g, lambda 3 of F.
So it is upper-bounded.
The difference is up
rebounded by the--
using the counting
lemma, we find
that their difference
is upper-bounded
by the following quantity.
Namely, you look at the
difference between f and g
and evaluate its maximum
Fourier coefficient.
OK.
So if A is pseudorandom,
meaning that Fourier uniform--
this l infinity
norm is small, then
I should expect lots
and lots of 3APs in A,
but because that
is not the case,
we should be able to
conclude that there is
some large Fourier coefficient.
All right, so thus--
so rearranging the equation
above, we have that--
so this should be a square.
OK.
So we have this expression here.
And now we are--
OK, so let me simplify
this expression slightly.
And now we're using that N
is sufficiently large, OK?
So we're using N is
sufficiently large.
So this quantity is at least
a tenth of alpha squared N.
OK, and that's the
conclusion, all right?
So that's the conclusion
of this step here.
What does this mean?
This means there
exists some theta
so that the Fourier
coefficient at theta
is at least the
claimed quantity.
Any questions?
All right.
So that finishes step 1.
So now let me go on step 2.
In step 2, we wish to show that
if you have a large Fourier
coefficient, then one can
obtain a density increment.
So last time, we were working
in a finite field vector space.
A Fourier coefficient, OK,
so which is a dual vector,
corresponds to some hyperplane.
And having a large
Fourier coefficient
then implies that
the density of A
on the co-sets of
those hyperplanes
must be not all
close to each other.
All right, so one
of the hyperplanes
must have significantly
higher density than the rest.
OK, so we want to do
something similar here,
except we run into this
technical difficulty
where there are no
subspaces anymore.
So the Fourier character, namely
corresponding to this theta,
is just a real number.
It doesn't divide up your space.
It doesn't divide
up your 1 through N
very nicely into sub chunks.
But we still want to use this
theta to chop up 1 through N
into smaller spaces so
that we can iterate and do
density increment.
All right.
So let's see what we can do.
So given this theta,
what we would like to do
is to partition this 1 through
N into subprogressions.
OK, so chop up 1 through
N into sub APs such that
if you evaluate for--
so this theta is fixed.
So on each sub AP,
this function here
is roughly constant
on each of your parts.
Last time, we had this
Fourier character,
and then we chopped it up
using these three hyperplanes.
And each hyperplane,
the Fourier character
is literally constant, OK?
So you have-- and so
that's what we work with.
And now, you cannot get
them to be exactly constant,
but the next best thing we can
hope for is to get this Fourier
character to be
roughly constant.
OK, so we're going to do some
positioning that allows us
to achieve this characteristic.
And let me give
you some intuition
about why this is true.
And this is not exactly
a surprising fact.
The intuition is
just that if you
look at what this
function behaves like--
all right, so what's
going on here?
You are on the unit circle,
and you are jumping by theta.
OK, so you just keep
jumping by theta and so on.
And I want to show that I
can sharp up my progression
into a bunch of almost periodic
pieces, where in each part,
I'm staying inside a small arc.
So in the extreme case of this
where it is very easy to see
is if x is some rational number,
a over b, with b fairly small,
then we can--
so then, this character is
actually constant on APs
with common difference b.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Is theta
supposed to be [INAUDIBLE]??
YUFEI ZHAO: Ah, so theta,
yes. so theta-- thank you.
So theta 2 pi.
AUDIENCE: Like, is x
equal to your theta?
YUFEI ZHAO: Yeah.
Thank you.
So theta equals-- yeah.
So if theta is some rational
with some small denominator--
so then you are literally
jumping in periodic steps
on the unit circle.
So if you partition N according
to the exact same periods,
you have that this character
is exactly constant in each
of your progressions.
Now, in general, the theta
you get out of that proof
might not have this
very nice form,
but we can at
least approximately
achieve the desired effect.
OK.
Any questions?
So to achieve approximately the
desired effect, what we'll do
is to find something
so that b times theta
is not quite an integer, but
very close to an integer.
OK, so this, probably many
of you have seen before.
It's a classic
pigeonhole-type result.
It's usually attributed
to Dirichlet.
So if you have theta, a
real number, and a delta,
kind of a tolerance,
then there exists
a positive integer d at
most 1 over delta such
that d times theta is
very close to an integer.
OK, so this norm
here is distance
to the closest integer.
All right, so the proof is
by pigeonhole principle.
So if we let N be 1
over delta rounded down
and consider the numbers 0,
theta, 2 theta, 3 theta, and so
on, to N theta--
so by pigeonhole, there
exists i theta and j theta, so
two different terms
of the sequence such
that they differ by
less than-- at most
delta in their fractional parts.
OK, so now take d to be
difference between i and j.
OK, and that works.
OK.
So even though you don't
have exactly rational,
you have approximately rational.
So this is a--
it's a simple rational
approximation statement.
And using this
rational approximation,
we can now try to do
the intuition here,
pretending that we're working
with rational numbers, indeed.
OK, so if we take
eta between 0 and 1
and theta irrational and
suppose N is large enough--
OK, so here, C
means there exists
some sufficiently large--
some constant C such that
the statement is true, OK?
So suppose you think
a million here.
That should be fine.
So then there exists--
so then one can partition
1 through N into sub-APs,
which we'll call P i.
And each having length
between cube root of N
and twice the cube root of
N such that this character
that we want to stay
roughly constant indeed
does not change very much.
If you look at two terms in
the same AP, in the sub-AP,
then the value of this
character on each P sub i
is roughly the same.
So they don't vary by
more than eta on each P i.
So here, we're partitioning this
1 through N into a sub-A piece
so that this guy here
stays roughly constant.
OK.
Any questions?
All right.
So think about how
you might prove this.
Let's take a quick break.
So you see, we are basically
following the same strategy
as the proof from last
time, but this second step,
which we're on right now,
needs to be somewhat modified
because you cannot cut this
space up into pieces where
your character is constant.
Well, if they're roughly
constant then we're go to go,
so that's what we're doing now.
So let's prove the
statement up there.
All right.
So let's prove this
statement over here.
So using Dirichlet's lemma, we
find that there exists some d.
OK, so I'll write down
some number for now.
Don't worry about it.
It will come up shortly why I
write this specific quantity.
So there exists some d which is
not too big, such that d theta
is very close to an integer.
So now, I'm literally
applying Dirichlet's lemma.
OK.
So given such d--
so how big is this d?
You see that because I assumed
that N is sufficiently large,
if we choose that C large
enough, d is at most root N. So
given such d, which
is at most root N,
you can partition 1 through
N into subprogressions
with common difference d.
Essentially, look at--
let's do classes mod d.
So they're all going to have
length by basically N over d.
And I chop them up a
little bit further to get--
so a piece of length
between cube root of N
and twice cube root of N.
OK.
So I'm going to make
sure that all of my APs
are roughly the same length.
And now, inside each
subprogression--
let me call this subprogression
P prime, subprogression P,
let's look at how much
this character value can
vary inside this progression.
All right.
OK, so how much can this vary?
Well, because theta is such
that d times theta is very close
to an integer and the length
of each progression is not too
large-- so here's--
I want some control
on the length.
So we find that the
maximum variation
is, at most, the size of
P, the length of P, times--
so this-- that
difference over there.
So all of these are exponential,
so I can shift them.
Well, the length of P is at
most twice cube root of N. And--
OK, so what is this quantity?
So the point is that if
this fractional part here
is very close to an
integer, then e to that,
e to the 2 pi times that
i times some number should
be very close to 1, because
what is happening here?
This is the distance
between those two points
on the circle, which
is at most bounded
by the length of the arc.
OK, so cord length,
at most of the arc.
So now, you put
everything here together,
and apply the bound
that we got on d theta.
So this is the reason for
choosing that weird number
up there.
We find that the variation
within each progression
is at most eta, right?
So the variation
of this character
within each progression
is not very large, OK?
And that's the claim.
Any questions?
All right, so this is the
analogous claim to the one
that we had--
the one that we used
last time, where
we said that the character
is constant on each coset
of the hyperplane.
They're not exactly constant,
but almost good enough.
All right.
So the goal of step 2
is to show an energy--
show a density increment, that
if you have a large Fourier
coefficient, then
we want to claim
that the density
goes up significantly
on some subprogression.
And the next part,
the next lemma,
will get us to that goal.
And this part is very
similar to the one
that we saw from last time,
but with this new partition
in mind, like I said.
If you have A that is
3AP-free with density alpha,
and N is large
enough, then there
exists some subprogression
P. So by subprogression,
I just mean that I'm starting
with original progression
1 through N, and I'm zooming
into some subprogression,
with the length of P fairly
long, so the length of P
is at least cube root
of N, and such that A,
when restricted to
this subprogression,
has a density increment.
OK, so originally, the
density of A is alpha,
so we're zooming into
some subprogression P,
which is a pretty
long subprogression,
where the density
goes up significantly
from A to essentially A--
from alpha to roughly
alpha plus alpha squared.
OK.
So we start with
A, a 3AP-free set.
So from step 1, there exists
some theta with large--
so that corresponds to a
large Fourier coefficient.
So this sum here is large.
OK, and now we use--
OK, so-- so step 1 obtains us,
you know, this consequence.
And from this theta, now we
apply the lemma up there to--
so we apply lemma
with, let's say,
eta being alpha squared over 30.
OK, so the exact constants
are not so important.
But when we apply the
lemma to partition,
and into a bunch
of subprogressions,
which we'll call P1 through Pk.
And each of these
progressions have
length between cube root of
N and twice cube root of N.
And I want to understand what
happens to the density of A
when restricted to
these progressions.
So starting with this
inequality over here,
which suggests to us that
there must be some deviation.
OK, so starting
with what we saw.
And now, inside each
progression this e x theta
is roughly constant.
So if you pretend them
as actually constant,
I can break up the sum,
depending on where the x's lie.
So i from 1 to k.
And let me sum inside
each progression.
So by triangle inequality, I
can upper bound the first sum
by where I now cut the sum into
progression by progression.
And on each progression, this
character is roughly constant.
So let me take out the
maximum possible deviations
from them being constant.
So upper bound-- again, you'll
find that we can essentially
pretend--
all right, so if
each exponential
is constant on each
subprogression,
then I might as well
just have this sum here.
But I lose a little bit, because
it's not exactly constant.
It's almost constant.
So I loose a little bit.
And that little bit is this eta.
So you lose that
little bit of eta.
And so on each
progression, P i, you
lose at most something that's
essentially of alpha squared
times the length of P i.
OK.
Now, you see, I've chosen
the error parameter
so that everything
I've lost is not
so much more than the
initial bound I began with.
So in particular,
we see that even
if we had pretended that the
characters were constant,
on each progression we would
have still obtained some lower
bound of the total deviation.
OK.
And what is this
quantity over here?
Oh, you see, I'm
restricting each sum
to each subprogression,
but the sum
here, even though it's
the sum, but it's really
counting how many elements
of A are in that progression.
So this sum over here
is the same thing.
OK, so let me write
it in a new board.
Oh, we don't need
step 1 anymore.
All right.
So what we have--
OK, so left-hand side over
there is this quantity here,
all right?
We see that the right-hand side,
even though you have that sum,
it is really just counting
how many elements of A
are in each progression versus
how many you should expect
based on the overall
density of A. OK,
so that should look similar
to what we got last time.
I know the intuition
should be that, well,
if the average deviation
is large, then one of them,
one of these terms, should
have the density increment.
If you try to do the next
step somewhat naively,
you run into an issue,
because it could be--
now, here you have k terms.
It could be that you have all
the densities except for one
going up only slightly, and one
density dropping dramatically,
in which case you may not
have a significant density
increment, all right?
So we want to show that
on some progression
the density increases
significantly.
So far, from this
inequality, we just
know that there is some
subprogression where
the density changes
significantly.
But of course, the overall
density, the average density,
should remain constant.
So if some goes up,
others must go down.
But if you just try to
do an averaging argument,
you have to be careful, OK?
So there was a trick last
time, which we didn't really
need last time, but now,
it's much more useful, where
I want to show
that if this holds,
then some P i sees
a large energy--
sees a large density increment.
And to do that, let me rewrite
the sum as the following,
so I keep the same expression.
And I add a term, which
is the same thing,
but without the absolute value.
OK, so you see these
guys, they total to 0,
so adding that term doesn't
change my expression.
But now, the summand
is always non-negative.
So it's either 0 or
twice this number,
depending on the
sign of that number.
OK.
So comparing left-hand
side and right-hand side,
we see that there
must be some i.
So hence, there exists some eye
such that the left-hand side--
the i-th term on
the left hand side
is less than or equal
to the i-th term
on the right-hand side.
And in particular, that
term should be positive,
so it implies--
OK, so how can you
get this inequality?
It implies simply that the
restriction of a to this P i
is at least alpha plus alpha
squared over 40 times P i.
So this claim here just says
that on the i-th progression,
there's a significant
energy increment.
If it's more decrement,
that term would have been 0.
So remember that.
OK.
So this achieves what we
were looking for in step 2,
namely to find that there
is a density increment
on some long subprogression.
OK, so now we can go to
step 3, which is basically
the same as what we saw
last time, where now we
want to iterate this
density increment.
OK, so it's basically the
same argument as last time,
but you start with
density alpha,
and each step in the
iteration, the density
goes up quite a bit.
And we want to control
the total number of steps,
knowing that the final
density is at most 1, always.
OK.
So how many steps can you take?
Right, so this was the same
argument that we saw last time.
We see that starting with
alpha, alpha 0 being alpha,
it doubles after a certain
number of steps, right?
So we double after--
OK, so how many
steps do you need?
Well, I want to get
from alpha to 2 alpha.
So I need at most
alpha over 40 steps.
OK, so last time I
was slightly sloppy.
And so there's basically a
floor, upper floor down--
rounding up or down situation.
But I should add a plus 1.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't
it be 40 over alpha?
YUFEI ZHAO: 40-- thank you.
40 over alpha, yeah.
So you double after at
most that many steps.
And then now, you add
density at least 2 alpha.
So we double after at most 20
over alpha steps, and so on.
And we double at most--
well, basically, log sub
2 of 1 over alpha times.
OK, so anyway, putting
everything together,
we see that the
total number of steps
is at most on the
order of 1 over alpha.
When you stop, you can
only stop for one reason,
because in the--
yeah.
So, yeah.
So in step 1,
remember, the iteration
said that the
process terminates.
The process can always go
on, and then terminates
if the length--
so you're now at
step i, so let N i be
the length of the progression,
that step i is at most C times
alpha i to the minus 12th.
So we have a--
right, so provided
that N is large enough,
you can always pass
to a subprogression.
And here, when you pass to
subprogression, of course,
you can re-label
that subprogression.
And it's now, you
know, 1 through N i.
Right, so I can-- it's--
all the progressions
are basically
the same as the first
set of positive integers.
I'm sorry, prefix of
the positive integers.
So when we stop a
step i, you must
have N sub i being at most
this quantity over here, which
is at most C times the initial
density raised to this minus
12th.
So therefore, the initial length
N of the space is bounded by--
well, each time we went
down by a cube root at most.
Right, so the fine--
if you stop a step i,
then the initial length
is at most N sub i to the
3 times 3 to the power of i
each time you're
doing a cube root.
OK, so you put
everything together.
At most that many
iterations when you stop
the length is at most this.
So you put them
together, and then you
find that the N must be at
most double exponential in 1
over the density.
In other words, the
density is at most 1
over log log N, which is what
we claimed in Roth's theorem,
so what we claimed up there.
OK.
So that finishes the proof.
Any questions?
So the message here is that it's
the same proof as last time,
but we need to do
a bit more work.
And none of this
work is difficult,
but there are more technical.
And that's often
the theme that you
see in additive combinatorics.
This is part of the reason
why the finite field model is
a really nice playground,
because there, things
tend to be often cleaner,
but the idea's often similar,
or the same ideas.
Not always.
Next lecture, we'll
see one technique
where there's a
dramatic difference
between the finite field vector
space and over the integers.
But for many things in
additive combinatorics,
the finite field
vector space is just
a nicer place to be in to try
all your ideas and techniques.
Let me comment on some analogies
between these two approaches
and compare the bounds.
So on one hand--
OK, so we saw last time
this proof in F3 to the N,
and now in the integers
inside this interval of length
N. So let me write
uppercase N in both cases
to be the size of the
overall ambient space.
OK, so what kind of bounds
do we get in both situations?
So last time, for--
in F3 to the N, we
got a bound which
is of the order N over log N,
whereas today, the bound is
somewhat worse.
It's a little bit worse.
Now we lose an extra log.
So where do we lose an
extra log in this argument?
So where does these
two argument--
where do these two arguments
differ, quantitatively?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: When you're dividing
by 3 versus [INAUDIBLE]??
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, so
you're dividing by--
so here, in each
iteration, over here,
your size of the iteration--
I mean, each iteration
the size of the space
goes down by a factor of
3, whereas over here, it
could go down by a cube root.
And that's precisely right.
So that explains for this
extra log in the balance.
So while this is
a great analogy,
it's not a perfect analogy.
You see there is this
divergence here between the two
situations.
And so then you
might ask, is there
some way to avoid the
loss, this extra log factor
loss over here?
Is there some way to
carry out the strategy
that we did last
time in a way that
is much more faithful to
that strategy of passing down
to subspaces.
So here, we pass
to progressions.
And because we have to do this
extra pigeonhole-type argument,
it was somewhat lost--
we lost a power, which
translated into this extra log.
So it turns out there
is some way to do this.
So let me just
briefly mention what's
the idea that is
involved, all right?
So last time, we
went down from--
so the main objects
that we were passing
would start with a vector
space and pass down
to a subspace, which is
also a vector space, right?
So you can define subspaces in
F3 to the N by the following.
So I can start with some set
of characters U, and I define--
some set of characters
S, and I define
U sub S to be basically the
orthogonal complement of S.
OK, so this is a subspace.
And these were the
kind of subspace
that we saw last time, because
the S's or the R's that
came out of the proof last
time, every time we saw one,
we threw it in.
We cut down to a smaller
subspace, and we repeat.
But the progressions, they
don't really look like this.
So the question is,
is there some way
to do this argument so that
you end up with progressions,
and looked like that?
And it turns out there is a way.
And there are these
objects, which
we'll see more later in this
course, called Bohr sets.
OK, so they were
used by Bourgain
to mimic this Machoulin argument
that we saw last time more
faithfully into
the integers, where
we're going to come up with some
set of integers that resemble--
much more closely resemble
this notion of subspaces
in the finite field setting.
And for this, it's much
easier to work inside a group.
So instead of working
in the integers,
let's work inside and Z mod nZ.
So we can do Fourier
transform in Z mod nZ, so
the discrete Fourier
analysis here.
So in Z mod nZ, we define--
so given a S, let's
define this Bohr
set to be the set of
elements of Z mod nZ such
that if you look at what
really is supposed to resemble
this thing over here, OK?
If this quantity is
small for all S--
OK, so we put that element
into this Bohr set.
OK, so these sets, they function
much more like subspaces.
So there are the
analog of subspaces
inside Z mod nZ, which,
you know, n is prime,
has no subgroups.
It has no natural
subspace structure.
But by looking at
these Bohr sets,
they provide a
natural way to set up
this argument so that you can--
but with much more
technicalities,
repeat these kind of arguments
more similar to last time,
but passing not to
subspaces but to Bohr sets.
And then with quite
a bit of extra work,
one can obtain bounds of the
quantity N over a poly log N.
So the current best bound
I mentioned last time
is of this type, which is
through further refinements
of this technique.
The last thing I
want to mention today
is, so far we've been
talking about 3APs.
So what about four term
arithmetic progressions?
OK, do any of the things that we
talk about here work for 4APs?
And there's an analogy to be
made here compared to what
we discussed with graphs.
So in graphs, we had a triangle
counting lemma and a triangle
removal lemma.
And then we said
that to prove 4APs,
we would need the hypergraph
version, the simplex removal
lemma, hypergraph
regularity lemma.
And that was much
more difficult.
And that analogy
carries through,
and the same kind of
difficulties that come up.
So it can be done, but
you need something more.
And the main message I
want you to take away
is that 4APs, while we
had a counting lemma that
says that the
Fourier coefficients,
so the Fourier transform,
controls 3AP counts,
it turns out the same
is not true for 4APs.
So the Fourier does
not control 4AP counts.
Let me give you some--
OK.
So in fact, in the
homework for this week,
there's a specific example of
a set where it has uniformly
small Fourier coefficients.
But that's the wrong
number of 4APs.
So the following-- it is true--
OK, so it is true that you
have Szemerédi's term in--
let's just talk about
the finite field setting,
where things are a
bit easier to discuss.
So it is true that the size
of the biggest subset of F5
to the N is a tiny
fraction-- it's a little, one
fraction of the entire space.
OK, I use F5 here,
because if I set F3,
it doesn't make sense
to talk about 4APs.
So F5, but it doesn't really
matter which specific field.
So you can prove this using
hypergraph removal, same proof,
verbatim, that we saw earlier,
if you have hypergraph removal.
But if you want to try to prove
it using Fourier analysis,
well, it doesn't work quite
using the same strategy.
But in fact, there
is a modification
that would allow
you to make it work.
But you need an extension
of Fourier analysis.
And it is known as higher
order Fourier analysis, which
was an important development in
modern additive combinatorics
that initially arose
in Gowers' work
where he gave a new proof
of similarities theorem.
So Gowers didn't
work in this setting.
He worked in integers.
But many of the ideas
originated from his paper,
and then subsequently
developed by a lot
of people in various settings.
I just want to give you one
specific statement, what
this high-order Fourier
analysis looks like.
So it's a fancy term,
and the statements often
get very technical.
But I just want to give you one
concrete thing to take away.
All right, so for
a Fourier piece,
higher-order Fourier
analysis, roughly--
OK, so it also goes by the name
quadratic Fourier analysis.
OK, so let me give you
a very specific instance
of the theorem.
And this can be sometimes
called an inverse theorem
for quadratic Fourier analysis.
OK, so for every delta,
there exists some c such
that the following is true.
If A is a subset of a F5 to the
N with density alpha and such
that it's--
OK, so now lambda
sub 4, so this is
the 4AP density,
so similar to 3AP,
but now you write four terms.
The 4AP density of A differs
from alpha to the fourth
by a significant amount.
OK, so for 3APs, then we said
that now A has a large Fourier
coefficient, right?
So for-- OK.
For 4APs, that may not be
true, but the following
is true, right?
So then there exists a
non-zero quadratic polynomial.
F and N variables over F5
such that the indicator
function of A correlates with
this quadratic exponential
face.
So Fourier analysis,
the conclusion
that we got from
counting lemma is
that you have some
linear function
F, such that this
quantity is large,
this large Fourier coefficient.
OK, so that is not true 4APs.
But what is true
is that now you can
look at quadratic exponential
faces, and then it is true.
So that's the content
of higher order Fourier.
I mean, that's the example of
higher-order Fourier analysis.
And you can imagine with
this type of result,
and with quite a
bit more work, you
can try to follow a
similar density increment
strategy to prove
similarities term for 4APs.